[Musica]
la libertà ho capito che non è grande la
libertà è qualcosa di piccolo di molto
piccolo e qualche metro quadro in più è
un bicchiere di plastica colorato è la
possibilità di camminare per più di tre
metri consecutivamente la libertà è una
torta una focaccia che mi posso
preparare nonostante io a disposizione
abbia solo un fornelletto elettrico
piccolo in carcere la libertà è un
ricordo piccolo un lumicino che la sera
genera ombra enormi per terra fatte di
sbarre alte con il dubbio poi di non
averla ancora incontrata finora la
libertà che sia per colpa o per
disgrazia non importa si dice che le
donne in carcere vivano la detenzione
due volte pagano lo scotto di essere una
minoranza in un'istituzione che è nata
dagli uomini e per gli uomini
una generazione che pensa ancora che la
differenza di genere in carcere sia un
dettaglio piccolo troppo piccolo per
essere considerato
con loro ci sono i figli fino ai tre
anni di età quando sono piccoli molto
piccoli e allora il pugno allo stomaco
ti arriva prima e quello e grande molto
grande vicino a loro tutto sembra enorme
persino i 14 metri quadri di cui nel
loro immaginario sono fatte le case le
cui porte sono ovviamente fatte a righe
e dove rumore è uguale a rimbombo perché
non ne conoscono un altro in carcere
tutto rimbomba di grande in carcere ci
sono altre cose c'è l'errore la pena non
come sentimento ma come condanna c'è la
rabbia il dolore spesso la disperazione
e poi ci sono le chiavi sono grandissime
di piccolo c'è il colore quasi
inesistente di grande c'è il grigio il
grigio con cui si guarda tutto si guarda
l'altro le altre ma soprattutto si
guarda a se stesse perché ci si abitua a
riflettere la propria immagine su quel
foglio di carta stagnola che viene
lucidato per diventare specchio ma che
riporta il grigio dell'alluminio di
grigio ci sono e cartellette i documenti
anche le mani sembrano grigie perché la
luce grigia
in carcere la libertà è qualcosa di
piccolo ciò che crediamo noi con quel
poco che riusciamo a fare con un
progetto come sociali made in italy è
riuscire a trovare la complicità nel
piccolo e nel grande perché la libertà
si annida dove meno te l'aspetti
ci sono libertà che superano qualunque
condanna penale e ci sono prigioni che
non l'hanno mai conosciuta una condanna
penale ma che sono tali ci serviamo di
cose piccole come un ago la sua cruna un
filo a infilare ci serviamo di cose
grandi come i metri e metri di tessuti
colorati e meravigliosi con cui dicono
che si vestano le donne felici di
piccolo cerchiamo la complicità di
ritagli di pellame che sanno e odorano
di boutique e che riportano di piccolo
dei marchi che più sono importanti più
sono scritti in piccolo abbiamo capito
anche sulle borse che confezioniamo per
loro di grande portiamo dei tavoli da
taglio delle forbici e sono anche molto
pesanti di piccolo portiamo la fiducia
piccola di potercela fare di poter
riuscire a imparare il mestiere che i
maestri artigiani hanno donato al nostro
paese per renderlo grande nel mondo
ancora oggi l'italia è considerata tale
per questo mestiere
la fiducia di potercela fare di poterlo
imparare con quelle mani grigie e gonfie
che invece possono diventare capaci di
lavorare su cose fini e belle il lavoro
con sociali made in italy e più in
generale con la cooperativa dice che da
25 anni lavora al fianco delle donne
detenute mi fa sentire piccola piccola
ha obiettivi enormi che a volte e spesso
anzi raggiunge anche eppure anni fa
sentire piccola perché perché non
sconfigge il male come speravo potessi
fare da bambina non lo sa fare però
offre un buon motivo un motivo per
pensare che la via d'uscita all'inizio è
sempre piccola piccola e diventa più
grande e man mano che si avanza nella
strada per raggiungerla
insegna cosa insegnare la bellezza in un
luogo che di bello non sa niente
una bellezza che è fatta di regole di
cura di attenzione di dettagli a persone
piccole che delle regole non sapevano
cosa farsene
non sanno cosa farsene pensando che
siano nocive alla loro libertà sociali
parla di colore le le educa ad abbinarli
anche il grigio che è un colore che sa
essere elegante social insegna
l'importanza di ogni singolo punto
cucito di come la tensione sbagliata di
un filo possa fare la differenza
insegnato cari materiali a riconoscerli
a proteggerli insegna a vedersi in un
modo diverso porta dentro nei luoghi
angusti e anche silenti un rumore come
quello della macchina da cucire e un
movimento dolce come quello delle mani
con cui ricostruire la propria libertà e
porta dentro persone uomini e donne che
hanno saputo fare diventare il proprio
nome grande
so cosa attraverso il genio creativo
attraverso l'impegno la forza la
determinazione e allora ripartiamo da
qui da quel lumicino dalla fiducia che
un futuro diverso è possibile per tutti
e che spesso si nasconde nelle mani le
stesse che ti hanno portato lì dentro
alla fine credo davvero che la libertà
sia qualcosa di piccolo piccolo ciò che
speriamo di essere davvero non è niente
di più che un fiammifero che nella sua
piccolezza una volta acceso a scatenare
l'esplosione
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]